students at sedway middle school
honoring a student who passed away
police say the student's death could be
linked to pills possibly laced with
fentanyl this story we first brought you
friday evening victoria saha joins us
from north las vegas with an update
victoria
yeah those pills were found on school
property police say it was about a
handful the student who passed away was
one of five students who took the pills
during monday afternoon's dismissal at
sedway middle school students walked out
wearing all black in honor of their
friend he was taken to the hospital on
wednesday where he died but according to
police it was difficult to know exactly
how ccsd pd contacted north las vegas
police about four other students who
fell sick they later found out all five
students took pills that may have been
laced with fentanyl his closest friends
wore shirts with his name and picture to
honor him his best friend alex sandova
said it was not like his friend's
character to take pills which is why his
death comes as a shock
jeremiah was never like
into that stuff he wasn't he was never
come on
from you know i think he got peer
pressure to do it
and that's what made him take it last
time i seen him was when the bell ring i
said was pissed out and see you tomorrow
north las vegas police couldn't confirm
or deny that the pills were originally
brought to school by a student but they
say school police found them on property
they did say whoever gave the pills
faces charges of possession and dealing
those other four students who took the
pills are expected to be okay the
experience vomiting and nausea reporting
from north las vegas tonight victoria
saha live local now